[Music]
[Applause]
carson palmer joining us his weekly pit
stop here were you on a team that a
coach got fired
i was trying to see if you were like
did you have a coach fired while you're
on no never no not not during a season
always uh it happened
well it happened one time to dennis
allen after the season when i was
playing with the raiders but not during
a season did all your former teams make
the playoffs
they sure did it's been a while yeah
it's been a while so bengals cardinals
raiders
they're all in yeah and and they all
could exit really quickly unfortunately
i was going to say out of those three
who has the best chance to advance
um
you know i think i think the raiders are
going to go to scentsy
they're tired they just played they
played a whole football game and another
quarter um they lost they lost feylin in
in the middle of their defense who's
been an absolute monster in the run game
they're fatigued they're tired they have
all this you know it's a huge emotional
swing to go from from that wind right
into getting ready to prep and get on a
plane and fly to the east coast so i
just think that's a lot to deal with
that's an exhausted team playing against
a really fresh team that has a ton of
momentum has been playing really really
well
arizona you just i don't know you know
they they um
they've looked really good they've
beaten the best in the game they've lost
to some teams you just look at and go
how did they lose that game and i think
the turning point i said this uh last
year i think the turning point was last
year when they went to new england and
they were rocking and rolling and
playing really good football and bill
belichick had a game plan that a lot of
people have really just tried to imitate
and and replicate and that is keeping
kyler murray in the pocket you don't go
for sacks you don't try to get him on
the ground you just keep him in the
pocket and he bill belichick gave tyler
murray fits and when teams have done
that to the cardinals they've had a lot
of success now in saying that i don't
know if if the rams can can have that
type of mentality on defense i mean that
is certainly not the way that aaron
donald plays that is certainly not the
way that that von miller plays those
guys just wreak havoc and go after the
quarterback so i don't know if that'll
be their game plan but a lot of teams
have had success against arizona when
they just force kyler to stay inside the
pocket and make reads and see over
people inside the pocket so you know i i
don't know what arizona team shows up
i'm obviously hoping the one that won
the first appearance in nla shows up
we'll see
the chargers raiders the strategy there
at the very end that
um it feels like people want to pile on
brandon staley the chargers head coach
because he called a timeout he was
trying to change his defensive personnel
and there was the thought and the
raiders admitted this after the game
that they were going to play for a tie
which would have meant both teams would
have got into the postseason
i have a bigger problem with the raiders
contemplating taking a knee
and and you would you would help a
divisional opponent make the playoffs
help me uh under well where do you stand
on on what happened in the uh the final
minute there of overtime
no you you played a win especially i
mean that's i've been a part of that
rivalry that is fantastic amazing
rivalry for both fan bases it's so much
fun to be a part of and when you have a
chance to knock
your rival out you knock them out uh i
was more frustrated with the entire
first half i i was wanting the chargers
to win by three and they kept handing
the ball off and they were getting
dominated up front they did not have the
offensive line to run the ball that much
they got a guy in justin herbert who i
i'd put my money on him eventually
winning an nfl mvp he's that good of a
player and they kept running the ball
all the first half just when you got a
player like justin and you got a
defensive front like the raiders who
have been really good against the run
and you've got an offensive front that
isn't great in the run game you just
have a back like echoer who can make a
play here and there there's other ways
to get the ball in necklace hands with
screens and quick passes and you know i
i was i thought the most frustrating
part from the coaching standpoint of the
chargers was just give the ball to
justin herbert let him go let him take
over this game and get you the playoffs
they took forever and then finally they
got to the fourth quarter and they put
the game in justin's hands and it was
out of reach unfortunately but he all he
actually almost won it as we all saw but
you got it when you got one of the
better players one if not one of the you
know top two or three quarterbacks in
the league like he's been this entire
season
put the put it on his shoulders give him
a chance to get your team playoffs yeah
i just i i think that uh the old school
nfl guard has a problem with brandon
staley with going on on fourth down and
and they converted six of those fourth
down calls what's your thoughts on on
that philosophy it feels like it's the
younger
coaches using analytics here
it's an analytical thing um but it's
also a momentum thing and and it's
you know where you stack up the the
charges don't stack up in the run game
with their offensive front very well
against that that raiders defensive
front so if you're gonna go for it you
know you have all these third and one
and two to threes and you get stuffed
and putting yourself in fourth and three
and four because you're not making any
hay on third down and running it
you know it's a momentum thing if you're
not if if if everything's rocking and
rolling and and they can't stop you they
don't have an answer then you go for it
on fourth down inside your own 30 yard
line like they did there but they were
getting pushed around up front and they
kept trying to run it again put the ball
in justin's hands you have a future mvp
you know one of the best young
quarterbacks in the game he's proven
that he can make it happen i mean they
converted six fourth downs just put the
ball in his hands and let him throw it
or run it but don't hand the ball off
consistently like they did fritzy would
you give carson palmer the poll question
i can
poll question is as follows who is the
most disappointing nfl team this season
brown's cults
ravens seahawks vikings saints
i think it's the browns i mean just the
hype machine that started with with
cleveland
you know all summer long going into
training camp and then as the season
progressed
it's such a good team and there's so
many quality players in that team they
just couldn't find a way to bring it
together play together stay healthy
enough and for them not to be in the
playoffs
with all the hype and all the excitement
about cleveland being back fan base and
you know they finally were deserving
this great team that that was starting
the season and and it ended up being a
dud and unfortunately it's happened far
too many times at cleveland well i look
at that that was pre-season hype but the
colts had seven pro bowl players
and they're not in the playoffs to me
there wasn't a lot of preseason hype but
you had
results during the regular season
and uh i i just wonder i mean they're
stuck with carson wentz
yeah unfortunately he's he has not
played very well at all and it's a much
easier division to win than the afc
north that cleveland was playing in when
you look at indy so um obviously another
big
big disappointment they're stuck with
carson he uh he unfortunately just
consistently has not made plays when
he's needed to and when they needed him
to make a big play he made a poor
decision or a poor throw and um you know
it's it's you look at that defense they
can rush the passer leonard is a
phenomenal linebacker on the top couple
linebackers in the league great great in
the secondary very well coached their
running back led the league in the i
mean just everything stacked up for them
to have a great year and they didn't
that's the thing too about it is they
didn't need carson winston throw for
5000 yards 45 touchdowns they needed him
to just protect the ball get them in the
right play at the wrong time at the
right time get the ball of their their
running back and let him do his thing
and really he needed to throw for 4 000
yards and throw for 28 or 32 touchdowns
but keep the interceptions in the single
digit to maybe low tens and that's not
what happened this year in indy
tj watts second quarter sack tied him
with michael strahan for the single
season sack record 22 and a half
why is it we have a problem with records
in 17 games but nobody had a problem
when we went from 14 to 16 games and the
records that were set
i don't know i was listening to your
segment earlier and i didn't even
realize we went from 14 to 16 and don't
know when we went from 14 to 16. but i'm
i'm a 16 game guy so i'm looking at
whatever record i might have i'm gonna
get another you know another game every
year that's another 300 yards and
another three touchdowns if if that
quarterback plays well so
you know i could care less about the 14
game guys i'm worried about the 16 game
guys now that we're at 17.
uh did you ever help somebody
with their incentives during a game like
like brady helped gronk yesterday i'm
sure some other quarterbacks helped
their players but did you ever were you
aware of incentives for some of your
your teammates
oh always always uh i don't remember
what the incentive was but tj
houshmanzada in the last game of the
year i think it was for another 100
catch year he had a 100 catch like three
or four years in a row and maybe this is
the fifth year it was the last game and
i i uh i checked like a little bubble
screen on a run play just and we lost
like seven yards on the play too and the
coach was pissed but
uh but he got his hundred catches for
the fourth or fifth year in a row
whatever it was but absolutely i mean
that is that is part of the job as a
quarterback you know
those numbers mean a lot to everybody
around you and the quarterback's so
focused on on wins because that's what
they're judged by but when you have a
chance to make a guy a million dollar
help help a guy earn that million dollar
incentive for that couple hundred
thousand dollar incentive you always
have to have that on your radar
did you have incentives in your contract
uh i don't think so
i'm not i'm not sure that i did or if i
think i hit whatever they were always
minimal in my contracts i think i always
hit them well you're probably making too
much money that they didn't give you
incentives
yeah i mean there's a threshold if your
league minimum you have a bunch of
incentives but if you're above league
minimum you have hardly any incentives
for the most part
did you care where you stacked up salary
wise when you played with other
quarterbacks
no not not so much um
you know i i ended up being drafted
really high before the rookie wage scale
so so
you know at that time there was no there
was no cap on the rookie salary and then
i continuously signed big deals
throughout my career and
you know it wasn't a focus of mine or
you know i know a lot of guys there's a
respect level they want to feel
respected and want to feel
um they're being honored with their
salary in comparison to other players in
the league some guys that's a big deal
for and then i know other guys that are
always underpaid it seems and don't
really care they're just happy at the
opportunity to play and um happy at the
opportunity for the team to have more
money to go out and pay the other guys
around them so i you know i think it's a
very uh it's it's to each his own kind
of a deal some guys are very focused on
it though what was that first paycheck
like
well my first paycheck i i
i was on the cover of uh college
football ea sports college football no
i'm not talking about what you got paid
at usc i'm talking about your your first
your first paycheck with the bengals
i've never got a dollar at usc then you
know that you got millions of dollars i
know not just a dollar okay so first
paycheck
well first i got like a 20 000 paycheck
for being on the cover of that video
game okay and then everything after that
that was so much money at the time that
when a million dollars came in i was so
focused on 25 or 30 grand whatever it
was i bought myself my first laptop
computer which
you couldn't tell me wasn't the coolest
thing in the world at that time
but
you know after i wow you really lived it
up there carson you know some guys go to
vegas uh you know you you got a laptop
wow
you're crazy nerd what a nerd
did you did you buy mom and dad a laptop
as well
no but i should have
[Laughter]
did you ever go to the atm and just
check your how much money you were
making
uh
no but i i followed along on a um
on my on my you know internet-enabled
bank account that i was checking out on
my laptop
throughout my career just to make sure
the checks were coming in every week
what do you buy what's the best gift you
ever bought your lineman
i was all i always really put a lot of
time and energy and money into that
because i really wanted um
i wanted to say thank you in a way i i
did a bunch of great stuff i bought guys
hot tubs and had them installed at their
houses one year i bought them segways
one year right when when nobody knew
really what a segway was
um
watches
louis vuitton travel luggage i always
went way above and beyond because then i
wanted guys too because as soon as guys
started playing well
we never resigned them especially when i
was in cincinnati they went elsewhere
and so i wanted them going to other
teams and being like
man you you got us a laptop he got us a
hot tub
so i wanted that spreading out through
the league and i wonder word out that i
was buying good stuff for my offensive
line it's they'd come and block for me
do lyman buy
the quarterback anything
actually my uh one year the best gift
i've ever gotten uh my linemen in
cincinnati went together they i loved to
hunt they all knew i loved the hunt and
they bought me a white uh uh a red stag
hunt
um that was super cool it was a guided
hunt that i got to go on
and i actually have that that red stack
mounted up in my house and that was by
far the best gift i've ever got
great to talk to you again thank you bud
we'll talk to you soon
that's uh carson palmer he gives nice
gifts
brought to you by level select cbd